i want to pull back the curtain on some
of your most iconic roles
in something we like to call behind the
scenes
[Music]
um okay i want juice dirt
fly on the wall anything that comes to
mind
when i mention these movies if you will
please and thank you
let's start with notting hill there's so
much
um oh give it to me hubert remember the
scene with the brownies we were sitting
around having
dinner and it's about who's going to eat
the last brownie well i remember
hugh bonneville who americans think is a
classy actor
what he got up to during that scene
deliberately putting
brownies on my chair so that i would sit
on them in my white trousers
and then they could all they could all
laugh at my bum
between takes oh my god i remember that
um okay four weddings and a funeral
well i yeah panic i remember the
director he really
because we had no money we made that
film for i a minuscule amount of money
and in 36 days
and he just lost his all the time he
would throw his cup of tea against the
walls
you have to you've got to shoot another
whole scene here it's two pages
and and he'd say yeah but there's five
minutes left in the day and so he'd say
stand against that ward it was like and
we just stand there in a line
and we just see the line with one camera
on it and that is there is a scene in
the film like that
it took seven minutes to shoot
[Laughter]
okay i'm so glad i asked okay
about a boy not a boy
ah he's a big star now that not that
baby but the
the boy nicholas holt by the way and
he's
hot yes yes and we chose him for because
he was such a
sort of nerd i know he i mean
with all due respect he he is
he's posed as a real outsider boy
and he grew up to be really hot
yes yes he did okay um
bridgette jones diary well there you
have
renee who was a a genius uh
being british bridget but i do remember
that she went through some interesting
phases on the way to getting that
that british accent during rehearsals um
she came in for the first read-through
and she sounded
like princess margaret dave very posh
and and then
uh the next time she came in someone
told her obviously maybe bring it down a
bit
uh but then she sounded a bit like she'd
had a stroke
and then she absolutely nailed it i mean
it's one of the it's
absolute triumph and and of course she
did that accent
not just in the performance but between
takes and she never
reverted to american until the wrath
party when that was the first time i'd
ever heard her speak
with her texan accent and i quite
honestly found it unconvincing
i love that detail and i love hearing
that
intel of her process great thank you so
much
okay mickey blue eyes
oh well that's jimmy khan and uh
what can i tell you about well i can
tell you that with my then girlfriend
elizabeth hurley
produced a film and we had a lot of
let's call them specialists or advisors
on the set
who knew all about the new york mob
let's just say that and she was
brilliant with them
if we needed anything done she would
flirt with one of these guys and she'd
say
she's going to sit on one of their knees
and
compare their manicures oh no you've got
such lovely jewelry and such lovely
nails
and they'd do anything for us you know
if we had a problem with planes going
overhead
ruining the soundtrack one of them would
get on the phone and suddenly
jfk had redirected all the planes from
that particular
manhattan manhattan my god i love that
story i'll never forget you and her
stepping out and choosing that versace
safety pin dress
you know there are like iconic moments
in fashion and that will always be won
that evening you two stepped out uh well
yeah it
ended up that way but i it was that was
pure fluke we were
uh you know unsuccessful actors or not
we weren't that unsuccessful but we were
not well known in any way
and suddenly this big premiere comes
along for this film and
she has nothing to wear and i think i i
said i think you can borrow stuff i
think that's what
people do they you know the big
designers will lend you something
and so we rang around we didn't have an
assistant or a publicist or anything
like that we
plucked up our courage rang round and
they all said no who are you and then
versace said yes we got something but
only one thing and they sent it round
and it was this is the one dress that
arrived
and she put it on and i i remember being
slightly startled by it
oh i bet you were hot um
and then with the rest is history it
became a thing it really did
you